[Music]
did you know
and i'm we missed is it just me or all
these la podcast that's just getting
gayer and gayer looking yeah this feels
like this you know what this feels like
i want you know that video with the with
the robot legs there with bom bao bow
bow bow bow bow bow someone will name
the song just by that but no this
reminds me of that bar from it's always
sunny
okay they did the competing bar oh yeah
yeah the fishbowl drinks and stuff maybe
she would stop pay a little bit more
attention to you
do you think they should be together
yeah um
herbie hancock it looks like a herbie
hancock video it's so good you're gonna
bust a nut
it'll make you come
um okay
brendan shop
was on we missed this this is a few
weeks ago was on the flagrant
uh podcast
to settle the trash tuesday beef it
settled as far as you know did you try
to [ __ ]
any letterman to your truck no
does that make sense no no no
[Applause]
no okay so then follow up why is it why
does it not make sense why does that was
easy you know
you know
it's her perspective and i get a
for it to get back to me it has to get
out of control are you okay
no nobody in this show is okay are you
there but but i get i mean
yeah
they don't they don't really bother me
schultz doesn't bother me but
brendan brendan sounds
[ __ ] he's getting dumber
i have nothing but love for her you know
i have no idea you know what her issue
is anything like that
that's fine that's her narrative and
that's how she feels oh good i get it
yeah yeah as far as kalila goes you know
me and her had a long conversation on
the phone we are good man yeah no one's
so are you because i feel like nobody's
good because the last i heard they said
you still hadn't provided the
the proof
when
these narratives online you know it's
it's a it's a
you know it's like a [ __ ] soap show
they want this drama what is a soap show
they want this drama well first off i'll
tell you he means like a soap opera yeah
a soap show the problem is he used to
watch a soap show with his mom when his
dad was selling computer things
his dad was selling computer things
computer software stuff he invented it
and installed it in ct software or
there's no drama like bobby lee is one
of my close friends
they're tight we just played a clip of
bobby lee going you bet you'll be
brendan schaub to me if you do something
bad to him yeah and bobby talk a lot no
one's been more supportive when i
started thank you stopped in the middle
of that lie yeah maybe bobby talked all
so like you know no one's been more
supportive of bobby than me everybody
knows that
you know this one time i was hanging
with my friend pete davidson at the
comedy club and we were talking about
how much we love bobby lee mm-hmm and
then it was right before i threatened to
end his career
and then we were a little hungry so we
had a little
besides rogan and talon delete like
nobody's been more supportive so
the name drops are are are are
monumental with him that's all he does
brendan he just name drops famous people
and foods brendan stands on a pile of
names to make himself feel more
important that he is
he stands on a mountain of names so when
it comes to kalila you know i and i
didn't have her number bobby i go look
give me send me your girl's number so i
called her and hey girl you want to suck
my dick in my trunk
immediately immediately no not even that
he just immediately sends a picture of
his dick oh yeah just no no comment next
to his ford f-150 raptor
just had a conversation you know for for
over an hour me and her good man i dude
doesn't seem like it because every time
we've watched the trash seems like
you're la good yeah which means that you
just both say you're normal bad yeah
you're just l.a good which means you're
both cowards and you're both like now
we're fine yeah and then you're just
going to keep passively aggressively
taking shots at each other dude when you
talk about the secret sauce kalila is
the secret sauce of tiger belly
and you were trying to taste that sacred
sauce which is the problem in first
place and turns out after you taste it
you realize it's just thousand island
[Music]
and the thing about once you taste kelly
you're hungry an hour later anyway
so
the problem of tasting kalila is you're
going to taste everyone that's tasted
her before oh no
oh
[ __ ] christ why does her [ __ ] taste
like the wind sock at the [ __ ] comedy
store on the mic
what
her pussy's like a bringer show
[Laughter]
you beg your friends to come with you so
you're not accused of anything
delilah sucks too
of the truth by the way everybody in
this situation
kind of sucks right past tuesday she's
such a smart [ __ ] girl no issues as
far as suing goes i think it's a
miscommunication did you see the clip
that they put out it looked like they
were very
angry yeah
again if if and i told her always come
to me yeah if you want to know come to
me
don't
don't ask anybody else about me just me
yeah if i'm being accused of something
come to me it's like a pyramid scheme
when they bring you in they go don't
google us because they're lying
throw this down because the government
doesn't like the easy money we're
providing
but you know what i mean you know you
you know i'm trying those
multi-level marketing schemes government
doesn't want us making everyone rich
exactly yeah
and they said that you had like some
i'm sorry i said it again
should we show marsh video phones after
oh yes yes cue that up dirt on her or
something like that i have to have no
dirt i don't know so
we don't know each other that way
they're making this up or whatever but
when it comes to kalila it's like i
don't know again i don't i don't
subscribe to social media so he doesn't
subscribe trust me this is scarce well
not in any account that we know brendan
but from the word on the street is
daddy's
thick boy daddy's got some burners
if she's getting that news yeah and she
subscribes to it she subscribes stops
assignments this is subscribing
he sounds like harry carey
i would be upset too and that's why i
told her i'm like i get it so i mean her
straight carolyn if you're a hot dog
would you eat yourself why is andrew
schultz slowly morphing into jamie
kennedy i don't know someone has to be
jimmy kennedy
jamie kennedy doesn't want to have you
seen his failed youtube channel yeah
it's terribly bad
not just him hanging out with like
rejects from [ __ ] jackass
seriously that's what it is
that's how adults do it but see this is
the problem with you being like so
detached from anything that happens
online that's a nice way to say stupid
but i'm with you go on is you don't get
to correct narratives about you in real
time
brendan can't talk on the phone and tie
his shoes at the same time
brendan can't tie your shoe probably are
you kidding me
come on
then what do you used to call brendan
velcro's job
like
this is probably the first time yo man i
had a custom order by jordans to have
velcro straps installed shits are tight
right yeah it's so cool have you ever
addressed what they said well who but
who else is gonna you have 14 different
platforms you could just go and be like
yo that's wild that's not true i'm not
saying anything there's no lawsuit i but
there is though
that's the you know why he can't say
those things
because there are and by the way can i
say i know why he's asking that because
he's to be fair to give him credit he is
actually being like but wait a second
then if they aren't true like say
something right called her up and
squashed everything's good instead of
they put it out there and then never
address what is out there and now
everybody just believes what has been
said by them is real
you could do that or i can just call
kalila direct like i did no that's been
squashed between youtube but the people
that have seen oh but but here's the
thing
buddy i know you probably don't want
this stuff but let me help you out here
he doesn't care about the haters no bro
it's it's dude he doesn't even care dude
haters be gone
i mean it just
bawling so hard
and it gets squashed so they just
believe that that thing that they've
digested is still real sure and
look he's a lot like opie he hates
haters
he's the worst part of his duo he sneaks
around behind the scenes and tattles on
people that's right he's probably filmed
people in the bathroom i'm not sure but
i'm just guessing that comes with you
know celebrity and all that [ __ ] so it's
like with that like
you know some stuff you don't have to
tell the public you know what i'm saying
like i'm me and kalei are cool bobby's
one of my closest friends man yeah so
it's like but it's the
problem brendan is that's not what
they're saying like i get it if
every time there's
every week we we we always see his
videos the two buttons by the way keeps
putting up of them sniping at him and
taking little shots at him it doesn't
seem okay
like with that stuff and you got to
realize when i was coming to comedy
after you talked to kalila on the phone
her co-host on trash tuesday said oh no
you're in danger that means you're gonna
be a dick to everybody you're not it's
not fine
again i get all you filled out
a petition in crayon
for everybody to be nice on the internet
yeah
exactly that's right she brought out
crayons and started exactly you're right
when you have this do you drive a truck
no yeah well not anymore
yeah you don't even drive a truck
hold on you don't even have a truck no
here's no i have a bronco that i got six
you had a truck though
a bronco it's a truck people would
consider a bronco
a truck
quick ask me if i have an suv just ask
me do you have an suv no no i have an
escalade
that's the definition of an suv oh okay
so you have a tr
he knows he's trying to do that little
technicality thing
you know what they meant to a girl any
big car is a truck
also
let's say you had a car now instead you
still owned a truck at the time in
question
correct no that's eight months ago
that's eight months so you didn't own a
truck before then no i i had a truck no
hold up
i had a truck i had a truck
so you've always had a truck
i was saying it's literally the most
famous truck
oj made it very famous yes
i have a truck but here's
the thing with that but did you park in
the comedy store parking lot or do you
have to walk through they wouldn't let
me a different place it was i got rid of
it after two weeks because you know i
was at the comedy store so much the
valet guys who has they've always been
great to me if you know how the comedy
store works unless your pass you can't
park in that lot
but he can because he has a showtime
special
right i didn't know that but i would tip
them like crazy that even when i didn't
have money i'd always tip them but also
any money i made from the comedy store
the improv the live factory i always
give to the door guys i never told you
this guy's a great guy yeah
yeah i know i mean if you listen
everything he says about himself he's
the coolest guy according to him he's a
great second coming of cte christ with
this guy are you kidding me
great guy dude yeah i guess so i'd
always give him the money
but he said that's a [ __ ] up precedent
to set though because if i go to the
comedy store i ain't trying to tip y'all
like that yeah
i'm nice
come on it's just different again it's
just with the truck they're like bro we
can't park this thing it's too [ __ ]
big right and i can park on he's like if
i keep talking about the truck they
won't ask me did you ask did you ask
somebody's girlfriend to blow me in it
that's why he keeps talking about the
truck like bobby lee's girlfriend and
kurt metzger's girlfriend
so i was a kid man so
again we brought it up maybe he we
really maybe he really thinks that
comedy is like an std that you could get
it like through a third party
if they're gonna make for the way i talk
you know i my entire business is based
off talking i thought this was from
being punched
yeah me too
andrew schultz has got some balls i'm
backing up i'm backing up i'm backing up
i'm sorry i skipped a little bit too
much
there we go so they gave me a special no
i what okay i got i'm sorry
guys i apologize i skipped at the wrong
time but like here we go when i would
read teleprompters when i had that legit
tv show on showtime they had me read the
teleprompter and i could see that and i
wanted the guy to be honest like hey
dude we need to work on your the way
pronounced words
your diction
but he was just like uh
uh i think we should use this give you a
special yeah i think we should give you
especially we should give you a special
it's kind of funny
you stumbled across these words like
it's a tough mudder
like it's a what i didn't hear the like
it's a because i can't understand them
on the count of the brain damage yeah
because you can't speak
there we go so they give me a special
period no i uh yeah which is hilarious
no the special's not i'm sorry the
situation is hilarious i'll give you
that
but the special's not hilarious so i i
have to work on it dude you have to have
to work on it really for a guy with a
speech impediment and then also i've had
since i was a kid man so
no you haven't we've seen the video it's
not a speech impediment you're just
[ __ ]
if they're gonna make fun of the way i
talk you know i my entire business is
based off talking i thought this was
from being punched
yeah me too i i honestly had no clue my
life would be my life would be easier if
it was ct
wait did she just say
royce
i don't want to do this anymore rice i
don't want to do this anymore did he
just say i don't want to do this anymore
that his life would be easier if he had
cte
junior seau shot himself in the chest
because he had cte only so he could save
his brain
to see what was wrong with him
that is a thing that did happen
chris benoit had some issues
i would call killing your family more
than having some issues i was just
trying to be uh you know
then i could talk because you've told me
about cte i don't have ct i told you you
of course
this is my favorite one this is the only
i gotta give credit man where credit is
due out of all the shows he's been on
this is the first one that's actually
been like no but you said you said but i
didn't say yeah i told my keys the other
day i was like here we go
it started
next time andy letterman brings that up
you gotta do the michael or irvin
a lot of cocaine
lots
you walked me to my truck
[Music]
dude he was a tidal wave
it's one of the only episodes i couldn't
get through no it gave me anxiety really
dude because he's just yelling he
doesn't love him but he's one of my
favorite people he's playing incredible
oh dude he's incredible the best
me so me and him know each other and
then when i oh he also knows michael
irvin who doesn't he know
he was like a big ufc fan and then i was
at a super bowl party uh dion sanders is
there a cindy ball party
that's like one of my favorite things
every year is to go to a super bowl
party yeah super bowls are great yeah
man i can't wait for this year's super
bowl i hope the bucks make it to these
super balls
can i hear this i want it maybe i heard
it wrong but it sounded like he said
super bowl oh dude he's incredible the
best
me so me and him know each other and
then when i
he was like a big ufc fan and then i was
at a super bowl party
dion
tim tebow dressed to the nines and he
goes shop in front of all these people
i'm like oh i say last dog what's up
give me some street cred because i might
as well been a [ __ ] worm nobody said
hi to me he goes shop in front of
everybody i'm like what's up bro and i
go to give him a high five like this he
grab i'm a grown man i'm probably 32
years old
he's probably 32 years old he is not
sure his own age he grabs my head and
kisses me on top of the head let's go
and then everybody at the party clapped
and then and mom and mom and listen hey
mom hey mom hey mom
michael irving remember remember michael
irving he kissed my head and he was like
you're probably better than me in
football and then he cradled me in his
arms
i also have
hmm because the fun never stops
i'll give you my my reason so you know i
love you guys man i appreciate you does
it bother you
when you get hate
uh i i don't understand it i think i
think that's because of on the kind of
the brain damage again you don't
understand much of anything
because of the brain stuff probably
other comics might be able to understand
it um
but i also i don't understand it because
i don't have hate like no matter who it
is you know like i try to help anybody
out even if they don't deserve it i'll
usually start helping yourself at comedy
man you really are just such a good guy
i i mean i can tell because you're
always telling me about it everything he
says is is
is there anything he can't do you know
i mean besides comedy
just as much as i can and fighting and
podcasting
that means i don't know
oh and speaking of thank you frozen i
always forgot about that one
so i can't relate to it you know so it
will hurt my feelings if i entertain it
but i don't you know you try to ignore
it when i say ignore it like people talk
about posts and ghosts and they're
usually full of [ __ ] i'm telling you man
i haven't seen anything about three four
years i see nothing so by the time you
get in pixels that ben pixels has on
your behalf though huh
so you haven't seen anything but you're
suing youtubers how does that happen
yeah how are you suing you by the way
obscure youtubers that honestly
are gonna end up with more followers
because you're suing them yeah
it's to me it has to be pretty bad you
know so i see nothing because i don't
think it's uh beneficial for what we do
right i think it's good to have your ear
to the ground know what the trends and
what schultz he's doing what akash is
doing and what you know nate bargatsi is
doing so that's good but as far as that
the the feedback in the fans and reading
you know youtube comics no man i i don't
think it's good i don't think it's good
so um
you know it's just the way i deal with
it and that's not for everybody right
you know but um it works for me
yeah does it because you don't seem
happy all you do is complain
and if you didn't know what people were
saying about you how did you how did you
know your family was in danger like yeah
what happened when it was threats you
said that there was threats yeah and
where are they sending you these threats
because you're not on social media right
you don't read any comments but you
happen to know that all the reddit
comments are coming from bobby lee
correct because of his investigative
team
yeah i mean some of us we're so feedback
dependent we want to look at the
comments we want to see what people are
doing and again no judgment if that
works for you do that dude but for a for
a lot of people it's like for people
that don't want to get better or improve
the best thing to do is to tune out all
feedback
every single little bit of it beneficial
criticism just tune it out especially my
journey right like yeah could be
triggering so i get it man it could be
sugar
when you're when you're you're an adult
it's like my journey and triggering in
the same sentence you should probably
not be allowed to be a man anymore
what do you have a [ __ ] live laugh
love thing over your bed like what is
wrong with you you know what i'm saying
i get it so as far as the hate you're
not telling me anything i haven't heard
you know what i'm saying like nobody's
harder on themselves than me
but but
you avoid any and all criticism nobody
is harder on myself than me says the guy
who just said how awesome of a person he
is and all he does is help people and
how great he is he's an amazing person
him and his buddy michael irving yeah
his best friend michael irving so
whatever you say trust me i've thought
it so it doesn't hurt my feelings man
right you know
and do you understand where some of them
are coming from
i they they probably i i understand that
we're just jealous haters that are mad
because i have so much money and i'm so
cool
yeah and because i'm so giving it's the
problem is i'm too nice you know
if you know oh this guy whatever their
agenda is their narrative is
yeah you know it's like i like that
brandon thinks that it's an agenda
i don't have an agenda against brendan
schwab i'm not trying to build a
narrative i'm just talking about what i
am seeing you know what i mean like we
don't sit there trying to go man how can
we take out brendan you wonder what
happens somebody sends me a clip and
goes did you see this i'm like oh god
he's an idiot there's no agenda
yeah because if you don't know me or you
just watch a special you just saw a post
of a ferrari
i saw a postal spark
you weren't on the journey [ __ ] yeah you
know what i'm saying so i i get it it's
triggering too because a lot of i would
assume the hate comes from
you know there's a lot of people that
don't have the balls to do comedy sure
as [ __ ] don't have the balls to fight in
ufc right
so they're not allowed to have an
opinion on anything you you did an
entire thing on comedy central how you
were terrified to do your job at the ufc
and you were shaking about it and you
lost and
you had that entire thing for let's
start with that and i'm not saying this
dick balls mean the oc of course it does
but
the thing is now brennan this narrative
doesn't work anymore because there's a
lot of people that do or do comedy that
are making fun of you now we've we play
it every day
it's not just civilians
[ __ ] civilians yeah so a lot of it's
triggering men right cause i'm because
my thing is
i've always had the balls i've always
had the confidence right they got a
great parent the word is unearned see
what you had is it's called
unearned confidence you have confidence
that you haven't earned
super blessed for that right that do
whatever you guys do
journey
hashtag blessed triggered do it man yeah
and i've ran with that dude right ran
with that to the fullest extent so
maybe they didn't have good parents
maybe they have something going on with
their lives where they the only reason
people hate hate brennan or even dislike
him or think he's not funny shitty
parents and you didn't get opportunities
growing up his special's actually funny
the problem is your parents sucked
mm-hmm
all right you hear that you haters your
[ __ ] parents suck maybe if you had a
better mom as somebody in the chat
saying too he also had an invisible
ladder
they can't do go to open mics so they
can't pursue it so they have this toxic
they're not friends i'm joe rogan you
know what i mean like they're not
buddies with joe
right right i can't like just become
famous for no good reason right because
that seems hard
they see me pursuing it it's triggering
yeah and they might be really talented
they might be funny but for whatever
reason they can't do it
and you want to throw hate my way i was
built for it doug
he was built for that [ __ ] even though
it's triggering you wanted to start
basically an fbi investigation on bobby
lee
to start with that
um you're assuming smaller youtubers
you've been having bent pixels take down
anything that is with you about it
including a bass frequencies documentary
about you
all you do is talk about all the people
that hate you please stop saying you're
built for it you're not built for it no
as a matter of fact
you're not built for it you're actually
starting to show signs of where
you're actually the cracks are starting
to show brendan
okay i get it brother i get it man yeah
and if i could here's the thing if i
could help you i would but you know i
there's nothing i can do i don't know
them i don't see it you know
yeah so he knows all the hate comments
about him
but he doesn't know it and he doesn't
see it yeah but i would help all of you
if he could if i could
but he can't because he's too busy
hanging out with michael irvin
in his bronco that's not a
yes seriously
yeah it's a tricky situation i often
think back to like
you know the scenario that you were in
with like
with the whole being terrible at comedy
yeah i'm with you man i think about that
a lot
showtime thing because
at first i'm like why didn't anybody
tell you and then there's part of me
that's like of course nobody told you
i think you might be getting a little
too close to home here
mr schultz
is he about to tell him that his [ __ ]
special sucked
but what did he just say i mean we
didn't miss it right if we just said was
somebody should have told you meaning
you shouldn't have done the showtime
special but of course nobody told you
because
of the rogan thing or
i mean
okay let's see it's getting awkward in
here
right it's like
people wanted opportunity from you you
had one of the biggest podcasts on the
planet at that time and this is during
like the podcast bubble when things were
starting to [ __ ] explode i mean i
still do
podcast bubble
yeah that's the opposite of what you're
trying to convey huh
there's no podcast bubble i think it was
sorry just because a bunch of la comics
started getting on podcast doesn't mean
that they weren't podcasts weren't huge
before that i really hate the
implication because la comic started now
there was a podcast bubble there's a
boom in podcast top
yeah of course
um and then you have
proximity to the [ __ ] king
oh he really is
oh
oh he really is though
joe so nobody's going to want to keep it
real with you and be honest with you
what if i get
this is this this is this room was too
real
maybe you know what maybe they had bad
parents yeah i think andrew schultz and
uh did you guys have bad parents bad
parents this is can i say bravo here
because
first time i've actually seen another
comic to his face
yeah well andrew schultz doesn't give up
be honest he's never really given a [ __ ]
yeah
and they're like they're like well i
would like him to suggest that i may be
going rogan right which they know that
you're a good guy you did it for me
you've done it for people and they're
like listen for three people ever though
so there are those out there if you ask
me to do it i've done it for three but
you're undeniably a helpful person yeah
when i was doing the l.a podcast nobody
was more helpful than you nobody lined
up as much the adelaide podcast run
sounds like hell mm-hmm
get as much so i understand how you
could potentially be in that city i
can't imagine you know why you can't
ever do the other we've done the new
york podcast one and that's [ __ ] fun
right i can't imagine doing that whole
triggered and live laugh love and you
know i'd rather have an intern sell me
drugs right that's way better
over there an intern will go running get
you kombucha over a gas digital they'll
get you [ __ ] dabs
you're right
marsha and i and by the way they've
already there's all been talk they talk
about it all the time so i'm not blowing
up anyone's spot merch and i showed up
and we're smoking a blunt outside
and the intern walks up with an entire
dab rig he's like you guys want to dab
i'm like yeah yeah yeah i wanted to this
place is
awesome oh like i said earlier it's like
hey you want a kombucha and some on it
no i want drugs thank you thanks
oh no no no or you want some coke laced
with fentanyl remember that yes if a
bunch of them
that it's up to you to learn from those
situations and make sure that yeah
that's on me brother but again all
that's from hard work yeah
again
andrew just basically said you shouldn't
have done the special and what brendan
processed in his
just
ct adult brain
is
you're right i work hard
i work really hard
nobody was honest with you because
they're afraid of rogan and he goes
you're right i work hard you're right it
works so hard at least he's listening
and that he got the right takeaway
and you're not gonna again i know you
guys know hustlers there's as when hard
when it comes to hard work yeah people
say and i i told roger and quit saying
this so paint this narrative dude you
take that professional athlete's mindset
and i've always had this dude i could be
a you ups worker and i just i just uh
you should be a ups worker
no please don't i want my amazon
packages to get here on time
[ __ ] grind man yeah my dad he's grind
grind set mindset sigma mail sigma
grindset bro not professional grinds
dude that's that's all i know yeah no no
no he's on grinder
the people are a professional athlete
puff ashley
it looks like
you know what it sounds like like
brendan just grabs a handful of letters
and just throws them in his mouth
vomits them out
i know professional athletes have
horrible work ethics it's just it's a
it's a it's a you know it's a it's a
trait of somebody like my my
look here we go again
schultz just basically said you
shouldn't have done this showtime
special right and what he's doing is
yeah man i [ __ ] grind i grind all the
time i'm a hard worker i'm 99 prime time
nine to five i'm drawing all the time
seriously
father-in-law works at walmart did he
great father-in-law
his father-in-law he knows what he said
he said his father-in-law
jesus man um
my my father-in-law works at walmart
he grinds his ass off dude yeah he
doesn't own the company he's a manager
at walmart yeah
not one of the waltons
[Laughter]
the
desoto and woodland hills yeah because
the joke first off i can give credit to
both of them their joke was pretty funny
that was hey on the side of the truck i
get it that's funny
and then you know what brandon goes i'm
gonna tag onto this joke guess what i'm
doing i'm gonna name a walmart specific
walmart i'm gonna give you the
directions to it
why
that's why they call them brendon
mapquest shop that's right the one on
the soto do one buy with wawa is and the
panera
shut the [ __ ] up brenden are we getting
milkshakes remember that one oh god are
we getting milk remember are we getting
milkshakes that was a nice tag that had
nothing to do with the jokes